now I feel like there's been an awful
lot said about you one headline who is
delvin's the hippie turned Eco Tycoon
funding the green zealots so how would
you describe yourself
uh I'm definitely hippie or an xcp I
don't think I'm uh I'm a funder of
zealots or a zealot myself which I've
also been called I've been called many
many things actually and and I think you
know it I don't I don't give her much
attention I'm a first and foremost an
environmentalist I care passionately
about the uh the unsustainability of the
world that we live in and I've spent the
last three decades of pioneering a
number of different approaches to the
green economy and energy in transport in
food in football in diamonds all kinds
of stuff to try and bring about a green
Britain my all of my work all of my
focus on the creation of a green Britain
there's been I guess
I guess
um 1.5 million pounds to the labor party
over the last 10 years has revealed by
Sky News back in January and also of
course money to just stop oil
problem
for me no
for other people perhaps they're saying
I guess I guess what other other people
might say right is
look people don't just give hundreds of
thousands of pounds of their own money
for no reason what is the reason for you
giving the donations to who because I
mean I also give money to Greenpeace to
Sea Shepherd to a women's Refuge to
school breakfast clubs to food banks you
know the list goes on to the labor party
to the labor party uh the reason I do
that is because I want them to win the
next election and there's always a
funding gap between labor and the Tories
a very big funding Gap and I tried to do
what I can to close that Gap is it that
influence as well no
never and I'm always very clear with
them I don't want anything and they're
always very clear with me there's
nothing on offer anyway
do you think that at the back of their
minds if you've taken 1.5 million pounds
that there may be an influence question
there
for them I don't think so I think the
question is really surfaced by the
right-wing media it was a couple of
weeks ago it's been going on for 10
years right funding of the labor party
but if you look at funding of the
conservative party you know that's a
completely different uh story there's a
lot of opaqueness right you won't find a
funder of the Tory party willing to come
and talk to you about how much they've
given or why they've given this so you
welcome the scrutiny then I've got no
problem with it I I don't mind it at all
I obviously I don't welcome the
implications that come with it there's
some kind of deal going on behind you
know closed doors that kind of stuff you
know the idea that my donations caused
Kia St Arma to come out with the nullsi
policy that he has when in fact he
announced that a year ago in um
doubles and uh and yet two weeks ago the
right wing person like oh there's you
know there's just one and a half million
over the last 10 years Kirsten's got
this new policy which wasn't new and um
you know tried to join those dots and
say there's something going on it's it's
not fun
um but uh you know it's how they roll
and uh and I don't mind I mean we've
actually seen like for example recently
said you know it does appear that those
Eco zealots are just up oil are writing
kirstan's energy policy not content with
disrupting our summer and cherished
sporting events they're essentially
leading us into an energy surrender
that's a prime minister's View and I
think you said that was in it when he
was in Washington and you'd think he had
better things to do that's what I
thought anyway and there's nothing
original in that from Richie sunac he
has no mandate to drill in the North Sea
for oil and gas he actually has no
mandate at all from the British people
he should call an election
do you talk to kiss dumber and miliband
for example about policy I've known Ed
Miller Band since he was leader of the
labor advisor for some time and we've
talked occasionally and I've talked to
Kirsten twice and what did you say in
those conversations well the last one as
I told the the listeners of the today
program was a five minute phone call in
which he thanked me for donations and uh
the next day the sun ran a headline that
said secret meeting unveiled I told six
million people but I'd had a phone call
that's what the sun called it this is
the this is what we're dealing with
um it's interesting looking at Labor's
um policy on green energy right because
it is getting an awful lot of attention
at the minute so this is their green
Prosperity plan 28 billion pounds a year
to fund investment in the green economy
now labor talking about delaying uh
reaching that 28 billion because of the
economic situation do you think that's
the right call first I want to say labor
are getting a lot of scrutiny across the
board which is right because they might
form the next government it looks very
likely doesn't it and I think this is
what's causing some of the hysterical
approaches of the right ring media in
terms of funding so but what's that yeah
look it's an interesting point to me
what's your view on the delay to the
group I think it's not a problem I think
it's a very sensible thing to do I think
obviously we're in difficult economic
circumstances and there still could be a
year or a year and a half before the
election we don't know how much worse
the Tories will make it before the
election so it makes sense to say we may
not go at this completely in the first
year the 28 billion and it may take a
year or two to to reach that number
that's what I heard Rachel Reeves say
and I think it just makes perfect sense
do you think um you know there might be
other people in the shadow cabinet who
look at that funding right 28 billion
pounds a year that's a lot I think hang
on a minute we've got schools we've got
hospitals that could really do that
money why are we spending that amount on
one issue the thing about the green
economy is it's a good investment for
our country so it was education right so
the hospitals that are saving people's
lives yes and fossil fuels are not
for example for every billion pounds we
invest in fossil fuels versus renewable
energy we can get twice as many jobs
from renewable energy and almost twice
as much GDP growth from that investment
and so a lot of what we need to do to
get to a green economy doesn't require
money at all so would you like to see
labor be a bit more radical on green
issues then uh no I'm happy with where
they are
um you know it's not for me to say you
know I have my own opinion about stuff I
think you know if they become the
government I think there'll be the
greenish government we've ever seen in
our country and for me that's enough
because I also believe that they
understand the green economy the
environment issues and they'll do the
right things if you look at what the
conservatives are doing they're drilling
for oil and gas in the teeth of a
climate crisis claiming it will lower
energy bills excuse me when it can't
because we allow International markets
to set the price of the fossil fuels we
make here and we paid 10 times more for
our North Sea gas in the energy crisis
than than we used to for no for no good
reason they also claim it will give us
energy security but we can't get new oil
and gas out for four years if we start
today and after 20 years it's all gone
there's no security in something that's
here today gone tomorrow you you are
passionate right about North Sea oil and
gas you can see that there'll be other
people listening to this who think look
if you're wealthy it is easy to be
perfect when it comes to Green energy
right it's easy to drive electric cars
it's easier to make the case for green
levees or energy bills but I guess for
many people who might not be as well off
they think that the priority right now
should be all about the cost of living
it should be helping people feed their
families making sure that people aren't
going to lose their homes is right now
the time to be talking about these
issues I think that it is actually and I
don't support green levees on energy
bills they never should have been there
in the first place they should be paid
for centrally not because that's still
people's money though isn't it you say
pay for centrally that's still people's
money it's not like Magic Money Tree
right yes people are still paying taxes
no but it's regressive when it's on
energy bills because the the poor Among
Us pay the most proportionally for their
energy with green levees on it shouldn't
be paid for that way
um it's as simple as that and and
in terms of the cost of living crisis
that we Face energy our energy bills are
a big part of that if we transition to
100 green energy and we're at nearly 50
electricity on the grid now already by
the way if we make that complete
transition we can have permanently low
energy bills we can eradicate fuel
poverty we can separate ourselves from
Global fossil fuel markets and be truly
energy independent and and in a great
place the economic benefit to our
country is in excess of 50 billion
pounds a year kept in our economy rather
than shipped out to the rest of the
world uh now I want to just finish by
asking a bit about just stop oil and I
think we might be able to see at the
latest uh protest by then now this was
uh disrupting the ashes you can see
there Johnny birthday physically
carrying off adjustable protester I mean
some people might like the police to
take this approach when they're blocking
roads right I think I think you're right
I've heard that
what's your own view I think it's it's
comical I think that you know much is
being made of this in the news at the
moment and actually it was a few minutes
delay to the cricket whereas the UN
estimate that so far the client okay
you've made your major points on the
climate change a lot I just I'm just
trying to stick to the justup oil
Justice because it's disruption is the
point I want to make a few minutes
disruption in the USA four million
people have already lost their lives and
20 million people every year are made
homeless globally by the climate crisis
that's a few minutes of cricket
people are losing their homes and their
lives is it is it doing that cause
any good that's the question that's the
killer question though isn't it well we
don't know do we right because you know
it's a frequent question and I think the
frequent question but
I think that many people think look
Delane the cricket or
a bit of colorful powder at the snooker
is one thing but the disruption to roads
where people might be trying to use
ambulances to get to hospitals where
people are trying to on zero hours
contracts and they're worried about
making it to their place of work that's
something else well look I was on a
protest around Parliament square a few
weeks ago and they have a fantastic
process for allowing flashing blue
lights through it really works and there
were two while I was there we protested
for about an hour then the police said
look final warning they've got a
protocol for that the protesters
understand when the police say final
warning they get off the streets unless
they want to be arrested four people did
that day it's it's not as bad as it
sounds Central London traffic isn't very
fast anyway and it's a temporary delay
it's here today gone tomorrow the
disruption do you have any sympathy for
those drivers you know the ones who you
see getting out their carbs leading yes
of course protesters of course I do but
I have sympathy for the four million
people that have died already the 20
million displaced they're made homeless
every year already and the more that is
to come for my children and my
grandchildren as well and yours okay
um final question do you have any vices
when it comes to you know
the the green agenda she like you can't
give up your flight or you you know you
have sausages once a week or something
just once a week
do I have voices
I like to sit around a uh an open fire
sometimes Outdoors an outdoor fire
burning some wood but but I don't fly I
don't eat animals
um you know I mean I'm not saying I'm
perfect but do I have advice I like
chips but I don't think that's an
environment advice I'd just like to
that's a very fair advice to have thank
you very much